aux états nationaux de tennis
d'australie les juges de ligne ont tous
été remplacés par des machines pour
réduire la quantité du main sur le
terrain le système se nomme encore live
noms de la technologie bien connu
utilisé depuis des années pour les
reprises vidéo mais curieuse parce qu'il
aime toujours se chamailler avec
n'importe qui s'en est déjà pris à l'une
de ces machines parce qu'il trouvait
ainsi censeurs du filet un peu trop
sensible à son goût mais vaut quand même
passer sa frustration sur une machine
plutôt que sur une juge de ligne
n'est ce pas novak si la technologie
perdure au delà de la pandémie
on songe déjà à remplacer le très
monotone out dit par une voie
électronique par le nom d'un
commencement
quelles compagnies vont accepter d'être
associés au fait d'être out vuarnet
toujours en australie un papillon est
venu se déposer en plein match sur le
visage naomi aux accents l'une des
personnalités de l'année 2020 pour ses
prises de positions très fortes dans la
foulée du mouvement black light valeurs
sûres aux accords c'est un papillon qui
vient se déposer alors que soglo
c'est une mouche après lebron james et
rafael nadal qui a eu une altercation
avec une spectatrice à la différence
cette fois que nadal a répondu un doigt
d'honneur dans le plus large des
sourires mois la pression arrive pour
servir parfait
notamment dans une ombre terre est ce
que c'est parce que moins de monde dans
les estrades qu'on entend plus les
carènes ou c'est parce que c'est celle
qui avait le plus hâte de retourner ou
les golden knights de veilleuses ont
enfin décidé d'aller jusqu'au bout de la
signification de leur nom en
transformant leur joie en chevalier au
casque d'or globaux pour son casque mais
votre aide certains ont intégré le
visage de week-end dans leur folie pukas
alors que d'autres y ont plutôt vu une
référence à ces trois pays mais selon
moi c'est l'élément manquant dans
l'appartement doré donald trump
juste à côté la toile ou sur le casque
des golden knights de vegas je sais pas
si vous avez vu ses marques et en fait
de partager la vidéo de commenter en
fait si vous avez aimé saucède les
algorithmes à comprendre de ce qu'on
fait c'est chouette laurent dubreuil eu
nettement plus de succès avec ce qu'ils
avaient en dessous du casque parce que
90% de ce qui lui a permis de devenir
champion du monde au 500 m c'est cette
coupe de cheveux n'ont pas cette semaine
kosovo proclamée cheval n'a fait du
créateur du trophée vince lombardi est
en colère après les boks en raison du
traitement qu'ils ont fait subir à cette
oeuvre d'art remis aux gagnants super
bowl et je suis vivant je veux que tom
brady s'excuse pour avoir cavalièrement
lancer le trophée d'un bateau à l'autre
pendant la parade nautique de ligue 1
il faudrait quand même peut-être pour
lui dire que les joueurs de la lnh fondé
le plus beau graphiquement le détourne
500 avait lieu cette fin de semaine et
comme chaque année ont regardé la course
pas pour savoir qui était le gagnant
mais dans la tente un brin morbide du
plus gros accident après 14 tours il eu
lieu et de la ferraille ont été ramassés
la pluie s'est mise de la partie et la
course a été de nouveau arrêté tout se
donner un peu flatteuse brusco i was
casting qui sont aller se chercher des
commandes à l'auto pendant le délai mais
ça va s'arrêter plus vite dans leur
genre de course tout pour nous merci
pour tous et à ce projet
la vraie moustache d'un bon ma cape
comme will damas syrie il a dit je
donnerai pas parce que je viens de fruit
interdit